I wouldn't say there was a greatest
lesson like one single aphorism that you
could say that's the thing you know not
really I think that the discovery of
what the Buddhists call selflessness the
idea that the sense of absolute self is
illusory and that one is only relational
self and the sort of understanding that
philosophically resolved my
philosophical quest which is what had
been on and really presented the answer
so there the concept of selflessness or
emptiness is the one that I would say
made me feel most released and wonderful
and I have to say it fit with a concept
that I had naturally had from youth
which I preached from with which I had
defended myself intellectually from
being boxed in to various dogmas which
was the concept of infinity I was very
fond of the concept of infinity as he as
a youth before I really knew much about
it but and then emptiness and
selflessness is really in that same
category and it's a sort of a releasing
concept where there you know really
leading to a real experience of true
relativity not only a partial relativity
like Einstein's but a complete
relativity how does one encountered will
they say that you can only understand
selflessness yourself and they say you
can only really understand it when you
encounter someone else who understands
it they have this funny double bind sort
of thing in the tradition and I think
that does work out kind of in a certain
way of course people wrongly understand
selflessness in the West including many
Western Buddhists as meaning somehow
that you don't exist that's your real
nature is that you don't exist and that
it's a big discovery like a big sense of
disappearing that makes you feel better
you know but that is not the case it's
much more subtle it is a gradual melting
down of the rigid sense of being a
separate absolute self apart from the
world into becoming a relational
interconnected self that is more aware
of its relativity and therefore more
responsible for its shaping of itself
constant shaping and reshaping and aware
of influence
that also shape it and guarding against
negative ones and cultivating positive
ones because of the fact of your having
become having recognized that you are
and we always have been you know totally
relational and there's no non relational
component of us and so that's a gradual
thing that sort of Dawn's in a slow and
steady way and there are little leaps
and little moments like epiphanies but
the the idea that there's gonna be the
sudden poof experience because you sort
of disappear and that disappearance is
your real being of no self or something
that's the way people will understand it
but that's not great about Vicky blocks
from where I was born on 89th Street in
the doctor's hospital and I'm now on
27th Street so I didn't get too far but
and yes I feel that I'm more cheerful
now than I was ever I feel that although
my wife is fond of pointing out when she
see we see like baby pictures or youth
pictures that my brothers are looking
all scraggly and freaked out and so my
parents and my grandparents and I'm
always smiling and yet I have a memory
of myself as being frustrated and like I
was in the loony bin as I say like in a
crazy country I mean just to give you a
make it simple have you ever really
thought about ABC what it really means
abcdefg right and we just say that that
seems like the most natural thing in the
world to us but linguistically is
totally cuckoo a is really aa like cat B
is a vowel but the Liz a consonant
labial consonant with the letter C is
not really see it's usually cuff okay
you know with the vet letter up and so
on and so on and then the Tibetan and
Sanskrit alphabets are so logical and
you know cut up other than you know all
the dentals the labial of the palate all
the sibilance that we'll put together
and then they know they're know when
they're borrowing a vowel and they
always say it with uh and so on I mean
encountering those alphabets that seem
sane to me well organized you know was
like a huge relief I'd been suffering
with a B C D
like that was the Summum bonum of all
linguistic knowledge which is just a
higgledy-piggledy thing which is the way
Western culture is a little bit